afternoon I'm delighted to be
introducing Noland am rooks she's
associate director of the program in
african-american studies at Princeton
University she is the author of
hair-raising Beauty culture and
african-american women and ladies pages
at work in American women's magazines
and the culture that made them she's
also edited the book black women studies
our reader and co-edited Paris
connections african-american artists in
Paris 1924 1997 her teaching and
research interests include the study of
class and gender in african-american
communities during the late 19th and
20th centuries as well as
african-american history more broadly to
broadly defined and she lives in
Princeton New Jersey I'm in her new book
white money black power
Brooks argues that the only way to
create a stable future for African
American Studies departments is through
confronting it's complex past she's
going to tell us more about this today
after the talk we will of course have
time for your questions
copies of the book can be found at the
registers up front and the signing will
take place up here at this podium so
thank you everyone for coming out this
afternoon and please join me in
welcoming no leeway and mucks thank
y'all for coming I was telling someone a
little bit earlier a Friday afternoons
are brutal at Princeton for trying to
get folks to come out and it's a little
chilly out here today so I really am
appreciative that you took some time to
come in hear what I had to say I'm going
to just give you a broad overview of the
book some of the claims that I'm making
the book and some of why I think it's
important and then read a little short
passage and hopefully there'll be enough
there to spark a conversation so we can
exchange some ideas exchange some views
the reason that I wrote this book had to
do with my thinking around what is the
forget about african-american studies
today one of the the categories that I'm
struggling with for myself I make some
arguments I make some claims
ever-evolving
is that we need to figure out how to
talk about race we need a language about
race that works for this post-civil
rights period a lot of the language we
have a lot of the paradigm that we have
comes straight out of a pre civil rights
movement and very often and it starts to
fall apart when we just put it down
wholesale in in our present day and age
I was thinking about this in relation
some of you may have seen a interview
that the actor Morgan Freeman did on 60
minutes in December this is right at the
time when my book was starting to ship
to stores and right at the time when I
was really kind of thinking okay cuz you
know you do you do talks you do signings
you don't want to necessarily just and
read what you want people to buy because
then we'll why what people buy the book
right um but some of what he said really
helped me contextualize why we need a
language for talking about race and what
happens when we don't have it well the
thing that he got a lot of press for and
this is not to bash Morgan Freeman I
think it just is an example of some of
what's going on today the thing that he
got a lot of press for from that
interview was saying that today we
really need to think about if we still
have a need for Black History Month that
Black History Month is get Eliza's the
study the intellectual productions of
black people and perhaps we're at a time
when we don't need to do that anymore he
got a lot of press at least on the inner
Internet and at least of the groups that
I'm a part of right people really wanted
to say okay what do you do with it what
do you think about that surely we
believe that the study of
african-american literature history
culture politics and art should be
central to all the fields that those
that those productions would naturally
be a part of and yet at the same time we
recognize it's not always the case that
that happens so what do you do with it
however the thing that he got far less
press for
that really made me think was his saying
that we're at a point where we need to
stop talking about race and then racism
will go away right don't you see I'm
saying here just stop talking about race
and then racism is going to disappear
and I think that there are a lot of
people in a lot of places in American
culture that make those same kinds of
assertions that they're talking about
racism institutionalized forms of
oppression that continue to circumscribe
the lives of certain people right that
that is the same thing as talking about
just race that's certainly one of the
things that we see in the film crash
which I like actually like it is a film
but in thinking about the kind of
cultural work it does I think it really
points up and why we need a language and
understanding for talking about race
because and what people say is finally
finally you know America is grappling
with this history it's showing the
reality of what people are going through
finally America can move past its issues
with race because look this film has
shown us that everybody's racist and I
would argue that there's not actually
any racism in that film there's a whole
lot of prejudice there's a whole lot of
unfortunate I'm thinking about other
people
everyone is shown to be complex everyone
shown to at any moment to be impacted by
prejudiced assumptions as well as
capable of having prejudiced assumptions
but in the face of the images that we
saw from the Astrodome and following
Hurricane Katrina which were just coming
up on on six months we have to
understand and start to make sense of
the difference between talking about
race and racism and what we saw with
Katrina was an instance of racism right
and if we stop talking about race or not
um that's not going to keep us from
having moments where it becomes
where that there is racial inequity in
this country so I think that
african-american studies can help us
with this I think that African American
Studies as a field is clear enough about
the difference between race and racism
and can help us start to address the
underlying inequalities that lead us
every generation or so to start a go as
a country oh my god
we have racism in the country oh my god
we need to eradicate it we can stop
having those oh my god moments I think
if we take seriously the difference
between race and racism I think though
while I think that African American
Studies is capable of helping us with
that conversation I don't think that
that happens is frequently as it should
as it could because of what I argue in
the book some misunderstandings about
the creation story and some uses of the
creation story of African American
Studies and the short short version of
that creation story is in the late 1960s
we had angry black students who start
taking over stuff on white college
campuses and liberal often guilty white
administrators in order to make them
stop it gave them Black Studies right
that's not um that's a real stripped
down version of what you will hear
circulate it's always students who are
angry it's always white administrators
who are guilty and African American
Studies is never about an intellectual
contribution it's about solving a social
problem because that story is so widely
believed and then there's some there's
certainly some instances where there is
some truth today but that's not the
whole story
and I don't think that we've spent a lot
of time trying to figure out what the
whole story is and figuring out what
difference it makes that we may only be
telling this partial history and so
that's a big piece of what I'm trying to
do trying to start
thinking about in this book one of the
things that that generalised narrative
obscures there's a couple things that I
think it obscured that I think that
narrative obscures that that I believe
to be important one has to do with the
multiracial nature of the student calls
for Black Studies as I said in that
stripped-down narrative it's always
black study it's always black students
and they're always taking over something
as I started to do more research and the
thing if it is I knew this I knew it
but I hadn't necessarily written it back
into my head in my thinking about Black
Studies I knew that in the 1960s
students of all races were making claims
of the University right I I knew that
you know around specific issues black
students Asian students white students
came together to argue for universities
become more responsive and relevant for
America for the country to be more
responsive and relevant and yet in
thinking about it our relation to Black
Studies I somehow continued to leave out
all the black students at San Francisco
State which was the first Department of
African American Studies in 1968 and in
places where there were no black student
groups to participate the calls for
Black Studies and were all about the
belief that it was possible to end
racial inequality to bring justice into
America and for universities to start to
change in ways to make that possible
Black Studies for many of these students
was seen as the first step in this
larger project it if Black Studies was
instituted that was just the first step
it wasn't supposed to be it and in some
places like San Francisco State
there were also calls for Asian Studies
ethnic studies there's various ways that
people saw this happening but all we're
happy to come together around Black
Studies an idea that it could be the
could lead us
in this in this change so that's one
thing I'm trying to write back in to
this you so what difference does it make
that you have a multiracial group of
students instead of just black students
who are calling for Black Studies
initially the other thing I think that
gets left out in that short that
shorthand version of angry black
students guilty white administrators is
the role I argue of white philanthropy
specifically the Ford Foundation in
funding certain versions of Black
Studies crafting a narrative for
institutions about what Black Studies
could do that was picked up and
reproduced and I have had some people
ask me repeatedly to kind of clarify
what I mean here I really want to be
clear I'm not saying that the Ford
Foundation is the reason there is Black
Studies I'm not saying that the Ford
Foundation or any white philanthropic
organization is the reason that Black
Studies exists on any of these campuses
what I am saying is that given the
amount of money that they were willing
to make available for the
institutionalization
of African American Studies and they
ended up exercising quite a bit of power
in terms of how those programs were
instituted and how they were replicated
across the country and so I talk a lot
about the difference between their
vision of Black Studies in the student
vision of Black Studies in the community
vision of Black Studies if students and
community members believed that um
ending inequity and education and
opening the doors to people certainly to
non-white people but people have
different economic backgrounds different
racial backgrounds was a key and
necessary step to ending racial equality
racial inequality in that having a
presence a university presence in
communities was also a necessary step to
ending this racial inequality for
crafted and took a different kind of
tact
around what Black Studies could mean
what they suggested to administrators um
was following the 1954 Brown V Board of
Education decision that I'm sure y'all
are all familiar with right that ended
legalized separate education in public
schools and what they argued the the
McGeorge Bundy who is a key figure in
this work along with his program
officers is you know universities are
not necessarily doing that great a job
either and we see this issue of
education is all tied up with the Negro
problem that's their turn McGeorge Bundy
in particular said you know and I see
this Negro problem as having everything
to do with the fears and insecurities of
white men as opposed to some lack on the
part of black so I'm willing to put all
of the resources of the Ford Foundation
into solving this Negro problem and the
way that I'm going to do that is or one
of the main ways that I'm going to do
that is through institutionalizing Black
Studies so that leads to incremental
change so that it changes and the
faculty make up for example if you have
Black Studies they argued it makes it
easier to be responsive to student calls
for for hiring black faculty for example
if you have Black Studies you're a much
much longer way toward diversifying
curriculum for example because those
black faculty will teach one or two
classes that will start to integrate
syllabi in ways that's not happening if
you have black studies they argue you
will have a tool for recruiting black
students and making them feel
comfortable on these campuses so in
their in their desire to
institutionalize Black Studies the ways
that they did it and were almost
diametrically opposed to what black
students
to racial groups and students and
community members were asking for they
were asking for something that was going
to bridge the university and community
that was going to make substantive
changes in those relationships and in
the lives of community members it was
not for the students all about the
installation or academia for Bundy and
program officers in the Ford Foundation
it was all about academia and any hint
any discussion any any project that made
mention of anything that they thought of
is militant so by the time they started
to institutionalize these programs
anything I mean if you were putting um
black in front of a class of its black
religion that all of a sudden became a
code word as far as officers were
concerned for militancy revolution and
black power right if you said we're
gonna do black politics anything you put
black in front of those classes became
cold we're word buzzwords for something
that they were afraid of if you made
mention of any kind of community
component to what it was you were going
to do that could be you know we're gonna
perform a play once a month in a black
community for four that became code word
for militancy and something that they
did not think that they should fund so
the first half of the book really just
kind of goes through who it was who the
students were who McGeorge Bundy is his
relationship his changing relationship
to black power actually when he started
he was big advocate of black power he
ran into some trouble by using Ford
funds to fund the the Carl Stokes
election in Cleveland as well as the
ocean Hill Brownsville School District
thing you can read more about this but
that were very much wrapped up in this
idea of black power he funded these you
know the government's start going crazy
Nixon start telling people you know you
have got to stop this we can't have this
happen again we cannot have the Ford
Foundation messing around and
tipping the balance of power funding
groups like we see them funding them you
need to start you know open a file on
them and make them stop um laws
governing philanthropy were rewritten um
in the wake of some of these actions
were Bundy is seen it's too close to
Black Power advocates so part of what I
argue is so after going through these
very high-profile this very high-profile
embrace of black power when he got to
Black Studies um it was in some ways not
surprising that he would want to define
militancy and power so narrowly it's not
clear that he could afford afford just
monetarily as well as I don't know
emotionally to do much else so the first
half of the book really just sort of
unpack today um then the second half
talks about the legacy so what does that
mean for us today what do we see going
on today with Black Studies issues of
race and higher education how have how
has some of how black Studies was
institutionalized impacted what we see
on the ground now and a short answer for
that is of the vast majority there's
four hundred and fifty I think or four
ninety depending on whose numbers you
use programs in Black Studies um this is
a handful of departments but they're far
more programs the fact that over four
hundred and forty of the four hundred
and fifty or ninety are still programs
right are not independent entities do
not have the same kind of institutional
standing and legitimacy as traditional
departments is directly related to how
they were first funded how they were
first institutionalized and you know um
the work that they were supposed to be
doing which they could do as department
so there was no real Mena's programs
there was no reason for them to be
departments and do that work of
diversifying and incremental change so
the second half part of what I'm asking
is what does it mean that so many of
those programs still look like that what
does it mean for our ability to answer
hard questions
about change and about race today and I
also talked some about how given the
fact that so many administrators insist
on seeing african-american studies isn't
and for affirmative action program
despite the fact that few black students
actually take classes when their the
percentage if you just do a percentage
of black students enrolled at an
institution the percentage that actually
take any classes in black studies I
think Duke has the highest percentage at
like fourteen point eight or this is
true for two years ago on down to you
know somewhere around one percent but
the most that's taking any of fourteen
so what does it mean that we're still
wanting to connect them this idea of
affirmative action in the work of
affirmative action with black studies
when in fact and we're teaching all
kinds of students
um what what does it mean that we only
see it as again still addressing this
Negro problem or I sort of argue that it
gets used as if it's still addressing a
contemporary Negro problem and then I
also spend some time talking about
changing demographics in around between
black people and the lack of language we
have for understanding that so that as I
think it's almost thirty percent of
black students graduating from college
these days are actually a first or
second generation Caribbean or African
descent and at some institutions like my
own black students are actually almost
70 percent first or second generation of
Caribbean or African descent now people
say sort of what difference does it make
and it may make none but I think we need
to pay attention because admissions
officers are making assertions and
assumptions about the kinds of black
people they want in their institutions
and they're saying you know quite
forthrightly that it's because it lets
us get away from this history of slavery
it lets us get away from this idea of
affirmative action
it lets us
I'd step many of the issues we just
don't want to talk about now and that's
a mission admissions officers saying
we're looking for certain kinds of black
people to the extent that like I said we
don't have a language to talk about the
complexity of race today we can't the
conversation is trying to talk about
what that means why it matters if we
should even be talking about it tend to
devolve into finger-pointing and
name-calling in ways that don't get us
very far or devolve into conversations
about diversity where you're talking
about were you talking about all kind
anything people from different regions
people from different races short people
tall people I mean diversity starts to
me everything and at the same time
nothing and we're almost afraid to talk
about race to talk about racism to
understand that there's there's a
difference between the two and a
necessity for engaging in that
conversation and for fear as being being
labeled prejudiced or racist or
something so um the second half of the
book kind of talks about that so I'm
just gonna read a little little quick
section in 1995 fresh out of graduate
school I began my first academic job as
an assistant professor of English and
director of African American Studies at
the University of Missouri Kansas City
not only was I offered the position of
Director of african-american studies but
given the fact that there were no such
there was no such program in existence
when I was hired I was also charged with
creating a program of study leading to a
certificate or minor at the school there
was no budget there was no staff set
aside for this new endeavor there were
however repeated assurances about
unlimited financial support any of y'all
in academia know like that that's a big
problem I didn't know I was able to over
the look the lack of a definite budget
because there appeared to be substantial
enthusiasm for beginning and organized
program in Black Studies it was high
time
I heard from faculty those who
interviewed me kept repeating that the
school do something about its lack of
diversity and its rocky relationships
with the black community in Kansas City
besides I heard from faculty and
administrators alike attracting students
interested in african-american studies
should be relatively easy because the
school system was after all over 80
percent african-american most
importantly my soon-to-be new colleague
smilingly told me I was going to be
higher with two other black faculty
people so I wouldn't be lonely and
there'd be ready-made faculty to
participate in what they were sure would
be a successful experiment I now know
that the job owed a debt to the history
and legacy of Black Studies as a primary
tool to achieve racial integration in
institutions of higher education I also
now realize that Black Studies is often
looked at by administrators as a way to
address racial crisis in my case
unbeknownst to me there was the threat
of a lawsuit charging racial
discrimination at the institution once
news of the newly instituted African
American Studies program was made public
along with the fact of the hiring of
three black faculty people the suit was
dropped over all the advent of African
American Studies at UMKC and the fact
that I was hired to directed are in a
variety of ways testament to the
efficacy of forth strategies to foster
racial inclusion in higher education I
know that now but I did not know it then
at the time the title of director of
anything rang with ego stroking import
in my newly minted PhD ears and I did
not initially question the fact that
there was not actually a program in
African American Studies for me to
direct when I was hired my job in
addition to teaching courses in the
English department is serving on
departmental and university-wide
committees and integrating the Faculty
of the College of Arts and Sciences was
to create and then run that American
Studies Program and I looked for it to
the challenge I like my white colleagues
believe that because there were three
black faculty members two
african-americans one African hired at
the same time
there were enough of us to make a
difference I did not question the fact
that we 3 along with representing the
sum total of the african-american
presence and tenure track jobs at the
institution constituted the jointly
appointed core of the new program I did
not know at the time in its history
UMKC had rarely employed and never
tenured a faculty member of African
descent and I probably would not have
thought too much about why this was the
case in short I was thrilled when I got
the call offering me a job and was
delighted that I had the opportunity to
shape a program if not in my own image
at least to my own liking I had dreams
of constructing a program of broad
intellectual vitality and interest
cutting edge content and methodologies
and wonderful gender balance it did not
take long for me to realize that my
understanding of African American
Studies differed at times drastically
from that of many of my colleagues and
certainly from the administration about
five months after moving to Kansas
Citians City and starting my new job I
had my first indication that my I might
be in a universe different from what I
had assumed I got myself on the agenda
of the school's curriculum committee in
order to propose to new literature
courses I thought would be useful for
both the English department and the new
program in African American Studies one
course was a survey of African study of
literature from the Harlem Renaissance
through the 1980s the other was of
course on african-american women's
literature at the same time I wanted to
put the curriculum committee on notice
that I'd be back at the next meeting
with proposals for two African American
history courses I presented proposals
along with the sample syllabus for each
of the two literature courses and
outlined how both would fulfill the
distribution requirements and be easily
incorporated into the existing
curriculum of the English department
when I finished my presentation there
was a long silence along with quite a
few looks exchanged between the members
of the committee one cleared his throat
and said almost to himself I wonder if
we aren't moving a bit too fast here
I waited patiently to hear how exactly
it was that the material I presented
constituted moving too fast I was just
about to ask for clarification when
another committee member broke in to say
well the real problem here is she seems
to be suggesting that blacks have
written enough books to be taught in two
separate classes I mean do all of you
really believe that blacks were at all
the books listed here I swear to you
that this happened people are like this
is me being you know engaging in
hyperbole or something but in 1995 at
the University of Missouri Kansas City I
swear to you the curriculum committee
was dumbfounded that there could be
enough literature written by
african-americans to actually teach two
separate courses they didn't teach it
they didn't know this literature and the
meeting degenerated from there the
upshot the upshot was that I was told
they would approve one of the courses
the one on black women because they
thought black students might like taking
a class on black women's literature from
a black woman and besides Toni Morrison
is certainly someone we can all agree is
a really good writer in quote for this
group of white academics as late as 1995
Black Studies was something far removed
from a legitimate academic enterprise it
was merely to be put in place and
supported as a rationale for teaching
black students and housing black faculty
but not for changing the institution or
challenge it to change in any
significant ways racial integration
within higher education as embodied by
Black Studies had come to be far less
radical or even guilt producing an issue
for white America by the mid 1990s
however the result placed black people
who were often the ones doing the
integrating in a difficult position
often forcing them to inhabit in
ill-defined space between white and
black communities this was particularly
true on college campuses and African
American Studies was an academic space
within which those tensions came to the
fore and short the feel often came to
mean very different things to white
administrators into the faculty and
students charged with building and
participating in such programs to a
certain extent this had long been true
I've recounted this not in an F
to embarrass anyone at UMKC or Millard
event but because the story in many ways
epitomizes the history and thinking
around black or african-american studies
on numerous college campuses
I also relate the incident because it
illustrates the ways that Bundys and
Forge strategy was a success it
simultaneously created a situation that
continues to impact the ways that race
and integration are bound up with the
presence/absence meaning and use of
african-american studies of as a feel if
I envision the program in terms of its
academic and intellectual significance
the institution envisioned it as part
and parcel of their two-pronged
affirmative action effort to ensure
diverse faculty and student body where I
saw an opportunity to contribute to an
intellectual Enterprise the institution
saw a means to solve a highly visible
and racially charged problem attracting
black students to the institution was
certainly one of the reasons the
administration at UMKC gave for
beginning the program at their school
however as they began their program that
did not take into account the
differences in class makeup of the
student body or the historical and
social changes that had taken place in
the matter of race in the Academy within
two years I had not only left the
institution but the state of Missouri it
would take a few more years for the
other two first hires to join me and
leaving UMKC the problem I came to
discover was not bad luck with the
institution's choice of hiring and
absence of good intentions on the part
of the administrators responsible for
inaugurating the program the program's
geographical location or a lack of
community support the problem was the
conflicting history various contemporary
meanings and uses of afro-american
studies as a field conflicts that are
unavoidable in a field designed to
address any and all institutional issues
involving racial inclusion and exclusion
within American universities to be sure
the often rocky terrain that is racial
relationships in America has shifted
since the pre civil rights era yet in
many ways African American Studies has
remained static in the minds of most
administrators at the very least there
is a real distance between
the faculty teaching and such program
what the faculty teaching in such
programs and what other and the vision
others hold okay yeah butchered that
last sentence but um so that's the
overview that's a sense of sort of what
I experienced and I'm happy to to engage
in conversation with y'all I'm from
Kansas City and I actually have
experienced some of the sort of I should
just say lack of understanding but you
know I'm here I was here at school and
didn't choose you in KC huh oh no no I
think a little different but what would
you say would be the solution moving
forward I'm a little bit put off by
Morgan Freeman's comment that why should
we study black history I mean I go to
Museum of Fine Arts and I see these
trust khun's and they seem to include
the Etruscans you know who had a blip on
the history radar and they seem to have
all these different histories but when
it comes to blacks oh why don't we just
amalgamate ourselves into everything
else so I mean I'm a little bit put off
I'm a little bit saddened by mr.
Freeman's statement because it just
seems as if everyone else can have a
history but when it comes to
african-americans we should just you
know jump in the soup slopes big so what
do you see as the solution to try to get
people understand that we are a salad in
this country at least in my point of
view that melting pot yeah I just don't
think that that's a good analogy I mean
we have differences we should value
those differences and as a filmmaker
I've made a film dealing with those
differences but saying just because
you're different doesn't mean that
you're better or worse it means that you
work together different parts working
here's the thing with african-american
studies in particular um I think it has
long been the case for people inside and
outside of the field
um that we have struggled with at what
Ford did not necess
think african-american studies was
supposed to last on ad infinitum right
because at some point there were going
to be sufficient not levels of
integration in departments race was
going to be discussed enough in
departments people were going to hire
enough faculty of color without African
American Studies right so it was
supposed to be a temporary solution to a
problem that has to do with why I think
it got institutionalized the way that it
does but a lot even around African
American Studies you had a lot of black
thinkers and intellectuals who today we
consider race man you know this term and
like very politically engaged black
people from a period before usually like
before the 50s like race men so for
example Kenneth Clark who along with his
wife Mamie offered the doll study that
was a part of the 1954 Brown V Board of
Education decision that said you know
because of segregated because of
segregation black children are
experiencing high levels of self-hatred
they don't like dolls that look like
them right his first time social
scientific research gets used in a court
case by a little boy he was dead set
against Black Studies as an
institutionalized entity but this is a
race man right this is someone who cares
about the condition of black people
because he said we we our history should
not be segregated it shouldn't be off on
the side being taught in African
American Studies it needs to be front
and central along with him um they are
Tristan who was Martin Luther King's
mentor intellectual mentor and around
non-violence as well as you just race
indifference absolutely against Black
Studies as a feel but this is again a
race man this is not some self
self-hating don't talk about race just
like black people kind of person that
question of do you teach it off to the
side or do you fight to have it
integrated in the middle is one that I
think is more complex than we sometimes
sometimes
sigh I learned grief is the end of study
after Museum Studies Roman history
alongside every other you see there and
then of course the other side of that is
well but if not african-american studies
if not a feel that's charged with making
sure that history and literature and you
know is is paying attention to this and
is it gonna get taught at all right so
and that was the charge from the other
side when it's getting institutionalized
as as as people are arguing about this
is yeah ok but you're putting an awful
lot of faith and trust in history
departments literature departments
sociology departments who don't know
this curriculum who don't know this
stuff who aren't thinking about it in
for for teaching it right I think and
you asked me what what I think needs to
happen first of all honestly and I don't
mean this to be flip I think that we
need to talk about it you know honestly
I I think that we want to forestall all
kinds of conversations that get it messy
things right and then we want to point
fingers if you don't believe the black
study should exist you're some sort of
sellout Uncle Tom if you believe that it
should you're some kind of radical black
power monger right I mean what what what
gets lost and all of that is no an
actual conversation about how we move
for like I think we need to have a
high-level think-tank myself about the
role of Black Studies Black Studies
black power you know I'll say finally I
really find that and doing research for
this book that Black Power movement that
period following and 1960 following
actually a little bit earlier I mean
because King becomes a really contested
sort of figure earlier before he died
but
it's so under study it's so under
studied it's so under misunderstood and
people all become caricatures ray of a
fist and afro a big chair stands in for
you know a real complex understanding of
black power and you know in the same way
that black people race men younger
generation were arguing tooth and nail
over what Black Studies was going to be
younger people were arguing with each
other about what black power was there
wasn't just one model there was not just
one understanding and it wasn't just
based on passionate desire to tear down
what existed they were reading a
stunning amount of literature and
reading it with passion and willing to
debate it with passion and I would kill
for amongst my students today who are
able to crack lovely arguments you know
well-reasoned well argued but there's
not a sense of investment right in the
outcome um for my sins I'm sure Harvard
students are different Princeton
students so so I think that you know
studying that period studying it
honestly I think having non knee-jerk
responses to what people are saying and
I think actually taking seriously the
idea of Black Studies as a tool to
advance and address some of the issues
around race in this country is where
where we need to go it was a really long
one to answer I promise to keep it
shorter Sonia here was at Missouri with
me although you mentioned that Duke
wasn't is the institution that has a
highest number of undergraduate students
in black sliced undergraduate black
students in Black Studies blacks right
undergraduate black students in Black
Studies and that was something like
fourteen point something percent what
about in graduate schools and then
wondering how that do you have that
number and I'm wondering how that plays
into what's gonna happen in the future
of Black Studies who are going to be the
intellectuals in the future and as our
Black Studies departments then going to
be filled by non black there are only a
handful of graduate programs in Black
Studies there's only a handful of places
where you can get a PhD in Black Studies
now I will say I think we're just now
finding out you can tell me I don't know
how Harvard's
PhDs are doing coming out of Black
Studies and Rick's actually on the
faculty there what we're about to find
out I think just now how well they're
gonna do on the job market
and because the first class just is just
now well let's put three years old now
two years old
it just started Harvard just started
Yale's PhDs are highly employable that
you can get a PhD in black studies
however it's not necessarily black
studies they actually have this entity
called interdisciplinary studies that
all of these interdisciplinary programs
are a part of so it's a department of
African American Studies but not really
right so it has and those degrees are
all joint degrees so you come out with a
degree in history and African American
Studies English and African American
Studies and those are PhDs now they're
doing very well but I would suggest at
least of my experiences at Princeton
when they're getting hired they're
getting hired because they're coming out
of the one of the top two or three
English departments one of the top two
or three history departments and what it
is that they're doing it for us but
they're their side of their joint
appointment it's really not that big of
a concern but they are getting jobs and
then temple PhDs are someplace else and
then Berkeley and in northwestern just
started one so like when I say that
there's a handful really there's just
not that many temple phd's seem they
don't seem to be doing that great on the
job market because a part of the issue
for undergraduates and grad students of
course is can I get a job but all in out
of proportion to how undergraduates say
wonder if they can get a job with a
religion background right what are you
supposed to do with the BA and religion
I think it's a fascinating field what
are you supposed to do that if you're
not going to seminary but it doesn't
seem to animate quite as much and
concern on the part if you do our
history away so it's a liberal arts
degree it's an interdisciplinary degree
and yet you have to we don't we haven't
quite figured out how to explain to
people undergraduates that they can't in
fact get a job like with it and and we
have not quite figured out how to get
them to tell their parents who are often
like you're black what are you doing
again the P yeah you know any kind of
I'm not paying for you to go to
Princeton and get a degree in Black
Studies you are black you know it's
something that you know we're here and
helping them come up with language
for that is is really interesting I
don't necessarily at Yale a high
percentage of the grad students away I
know but that some people have cynically
told me it's cuz it lets you back door
your way into departments that you
couldn't get into anyway right but a
high percentage of the students are
right there I think most places though
for grad students you're talking about
predominantly black students I believe
you mentioned that the colleges are
apparently find foreign-born black
students more attractive than
african-american students and I wonder
if that's because of foreign students of
whatever color appeared to be better
prepared for college then American
students no matter what color yeah and
the thing is though I probably didn't do
a good job explaining this it's not just
foreign-born people of African and
Caribbean descent its first or second
generation so you can have a
mind-boggling conversations with
students where they will say something
like he's not black he's Nigerian well I
think about that right they'll be sick
because the person in question is
actually born in Brooklyn so for all
intents and purposes he is an African
American right
however in getting into Princeton at
this young man in question actually a
conversation with so I know he made a
point of putting on his application that
he was Nigerian because he had been told
by people in his community that that was
going to do some work for him right so
use your whole name if his whatever his
name was he had shortened it to
something that was sort of Americanized
use your whole name you know talk about
Nigeria that it's not so much that
you're talking about foreign-born
students not so much it said we don't
really have language for what do you
call the people right because they're
actually born here and yet claiming a
different kind of identity which is
attractive to claiming a particular
ethnic identity which is attractive to
admissions officers
because it's constructed against an
african-american identity with this
history of slavery affirmative action
and guilt how do you even start to name
that but it seems to be really having
ramifications in terms of who's going to
school the reason why I said foreign
boys right because they come with more
money and a different kind of
educational background and perhaps a
more seriousness about academics then
then American students do which is the
thing is though that kind of idea is
what's animating the choices admissions
directors are making right they're
thinking that well if you're talking
about someone from the Caribbean they
are coming to us with basically a
British education more seriousness
they're not gonna be lazy slackers blah
blah blah like these African American
students when for me the issue is the
extent that there is an achievement gap
in this country around education right
so they whether listen race but the gap
is between students who are African
American and who are white like that's
what they're tracking or Asian right
they always track Asian white and black
for the stuff that I know and there's an
achievement gap between the Asian and
white wealth is okay this achievement
gap between the Asians and the white
students right and then between
everybody else and the black students so
to the extent and that that's the case
instead of us sort of saying well let's
um turn our lens around after American
Studies to education what we know about
African American studies to education
and start to address what it is that
could lead to those kinds of
differentials
in numbers the regardless of class cuz
even middle class black people are
scoring lower than other groups um you
know we say or if missions directors are
saying we'll just get us some different
black people right I mean that's that's
a part of my concern not that we sort of
figure out what could be leading to this
gap
but just say we're gonna get these from
over here who are very often
african-american but the way they get
that foot in the door is by saying you
know I'm really Jamaican okay I'm really
trying to add in they went to the same
schools same kind of background it's a
comfort level on the part of those
making the decisions which is based in
some of what you're saying right well
they're gonna work harder they're going
to be smarter um yeah
did that am I still not answering your
question I agree but I think that the
the problem and perhaps the answer
encompasses some some other things
because when I talk to foreign born
black students who come here and enter a
secondary school one of the things that
they tell me is how how easy the program
are kiss yes and so as ancillary so a
recruiter or an admissions officer they
want the best students for their
institution and they figure if you know
if I don't get this
smart male or female student they're
going to go someplace else
I thought your talk was really
fascinating because it touches on so
many historical questions about Black
Studies I mean I was at Princeton when
Black Studies afro-american studies was
begun and I've seen sort of the the
history there and it's still a program
there it's a department up here when I
taught down there and still now as I go
back it's a very very vital place up
here where I'm associated it's now you
know the department and a PhD I'm
curious about the role that the Ford
Foundation played in either place if you
happen to know and did it set one as
opposed to the other on a different
trajectory
no actually and the difference really is
history's not about the four foundation
although the Ford Foundation has a long
history of supporting both and Princeton
was one of the first schools to receive
funding from fourth they did a faculty
exchange thing between Lincoln Rutgers
University and Princeton because you
know there weren't on that Lincoln will
be a historically black college because
there weren't enough faculty who could
teach so they wanted to institute after
American Studies but they didn't have
people who could do it so they gave them
I don't know it was like $30,000 or
something to spend two years figuring
out how to pay for them to drive around
the difference though I think between
Harvard and Princeton and has to do with
the way that it entered the Academy and
Princeton there were some students who
in fact took over a building demanding
African American Studies but it was not
nearly as contentious as what happened
here around African American Studies
there was not um the sense of community
involvement there were not as his it was
not as debilitating to the institution
the foundation of African American
Studies as was true here so actually the
President of Princeton
tapped what is his name - his name
anyway
tapped another way ma'am - head after
many studies because he did southern
history I really wish I could remember
his name I'm just totally Sheldon
Hackney there you go
because he did southern history right
and asked him to put together a
committee that would study the issue
make recommendations and help - to
Shepherd the program through the faculty
process so and then and then you know
people were hired to direct data mother
but the the way that Princeton's entered
sort of the academic universe was not
that contentious people there was a
demand certainly but it wasn't like
Harvard's Harvard you know they began as
a department
I mean Harvard got was has been a
department for a really long time since
1969 it didn't have to go through making
an argument later on about why it is we
have to have departmentalization in
order to function in this kind of way
although you know as as the world well
knows professor gates is really credited
with reviving the department so was a
department they weren't really doing
anything
professor Bates came along and you know
was able to take it into the
stratosphere so yeah I think but but
Harvard has certainly gotten its share
of Ford money to answer your question
for various for various reasons in the
what's significant about that is there's
really only 24 schools in the country
that got into this money so the thing
was once Ford started giving you money
you kept getting money if you were not
one of the initial 2024 and you you
pretty much get nothing and continue to
get nothing so it was really this kind
of handpick thing and certainly Yale
Harvard Princeton 10 have been have been
quite fortunate that way and you know
one of the things that people are
noticing is that at elite schools Black
Studies is actually doing pretty good at
schools like Harvard Yale and Princeton
Duke it's doing pretty good his faculty
off very often office space and very
often high profile kind of faculty
people at public schools and smaller
schools it's not so um there's a sense
in which very often those of us who live
in this part of the world kind of go
well of course it is self-evident that
African American Studies is vibrant and
it's going to be around and has all this
stuff going on because we're walking
around our elite campuses kind of going
look at all the attention and money and
respect maybe you know that we get it at
so many other places they're folding
they are becoming ethnic studies
programs they're struggling mightily to
keep the doors open so we don't want to
get caught up in the kind of illusion of
sustained interaction an ivory tower
issue I'm sorry why is this not an ivory
tower issue that of many that go on in
academia how do you see it you mean why
does it why do we care because I really
do think that discussions around race is
there every so often we hear about a
changing demographics so that you know a
few years ago everybody was going white
people are actually about to be the
minority in the country this is going to
significantly change how everything
functions at least according to the
newspapers right I mean it was sort of
all over everything and then you know
really what did it change and then you
know this is like well now Latino people
of Hispanic descent are gonna be the
largest minority this is gonna change
the power dynamic change the power
structure things will you know clocks
are gonna melt
time is gonna stop you know what what
did it change absolutely nothing and now
there's no point now well now we got the
same kind of diversity thing going on
amongst black
and what's it gonna change I don't know
maybe nothing but what I do know that
inside the ivory tower or outside people
outside are seriously struggling to make
some sense out of these kinds of racial
changes if it's if it's out in
California where they're trying to
figure out what do you do with the fact
that we're arguing for merit-based
admission into the UC Berkeley sis or
the UC system and what we know is Asians
would make up 85% of who's there if we
were actually going to do that so now we
need to figure out how to actually craft
an argument that's all about merit that
keeps black people out but let's some
white people in to be with the Asian
people and we don't have language for
that but it matters outside the ivory
tower because we live in a day and age
where university education matters you
know it makes a difference and what
happens to you and so if there are some
structural things in place that are
keeping us from being able to have the
kinds of institutions that we want to
have and enable the kind of
participation that we would like and
what's keeping us from doing it is not
being clear about how to talk about race
then you know I think we need to get
about the business of it and yeah as I
said you know really briefly every
generation or two there's some
supposedly life-altering issues wasn't
Katrina's 1991 rebellion in in in a
California right that was so widespread
that everyone said we've got to address
this issue with racial inequity in the
country people are in pain this is wrong
it has led to destruction let's get
about it okay then you know the next
time is Katrina right you keep going
backwards you didn't go back to the
Civil Rights Movement which at the point
at which northern White's saw what was
happening in the south people went oh my
god we must address this we must
eradicate it we've got to get rid of all
vestiges of the
racial inequality look at what's
happening people are getting beat in the
head and then we forgot about it
right um it matters because it impacts I
think the life chances of individuals
but also you know it matters because
some of us believe that America is
capable or more and if we ask it if we
ask each other and if we make an effort
you know maybe we can get two more okay
one more question
well you already asked me question let
me let somebody else I'm happy to talk
to you afterwards though positive or
negative
are there you more programs becoming
departments or more programs going from
african-american studies to more generic
ethnic studies or can you just talk a
little bit more about this unit in the
last ten years as I said you know kind
of briefly I think at elite institutions
African American Studies continues to
grow at wealthy elite read wealthy right
not just Ivy League read wealthy it
continues to grow it may continue to
serve the same kind of function that I'm
talking about where it's all about
diversity and affirmative action but
more is happening with it most other
places out west it is particularly
popular
I'm Russia from San Francisco so I sort
of pay attention to to what folks out
there doing is particularly a popular to
do this ethnic studies model so that all
the colored people all the non-white
people go into one department or in the
West in the yeah out west not so far as
California but say Colorado or so you'll
you'll have sinners for racial injustice
and intolerance right so all these kind
of code words for race are starting to
be people sort of like well we don't
really want to talk about
african-americans so much anymore we
want to talk about ethnic studies we
want to talk about race and intolerance
and not African American Studies which
as my husband pointed out to me who's
here today
pointed out to me and the the most of
the pressing moral issues that this
country has grappled with I've had black
people at edit Center right so but when
it comes to actually figuring out why
that is what that means what that taught
us right that we were at the center of
those pressing moral issues that
substantially change American culture
American society what does that mean
instead of saying okay so maybe we can
leave black people at the center and
still craft a narrative come up with
address the things we want to address
and increasingly we're sort of saying
let's take black people out of the
center and in the name of diversity just
talk about ethnic difference I'm not
against diverse institutions I'm not
arguing for you know only black spaces
although I am also graduate of Spelman
College in you know black colleges do
have some offer but I think again in our
awkwardness in wanting to talk about
racism in right now we're almost at the
point where to claim a racial identity
to really want to talk about that
brand you an American and a racist right
for anyone to actually say that I'm
standing here starting from an identity
that I see is black what if you can even
say that anymore you know because then
people will electrolytic is a social
construction but you know which of
course we understand that race is a
social construction and then um so I
think that and yeah these changes really
are I think African American Studies as
a field is continuing to be eroded okay
up until that that was oh one more okay
class that school like Harvard or
Princeton you can have students that
have the luxury of majoring in Black
Studies if you're a student at Cal State
Dominguez Hills I think the the parent
pressure to major in accounting is even
stronger when you're working forty hours
a week and borrowing money to pay two
thousand
the the corporatization I don't know so
much about my friend so I won't talk
about it but I know I know for mine my
students and the corporatization about
this luxury I don't hear what my
students talk about luxury all right but
I'm talking about the finest Dominguez
Hills but I'm saying even at a place
like Princeton it's all about what do I
do with it for a job which is a
different kind of what do I do with it
for a job than Cal State Dominguez Hills
right I mean and there is a different
class I did so what kind of job you're
talking about um may be different but my
students are all about being employed
somewhere now maybe they will go get
employed somewhere make a bunch of money
and then go to grad school to engage
their intellectual curiosity but right
okay and regardless of your major pretty
much I'm I'm pretty convinced yeah yeah
you're like 97% do so but if you go to I
don't know I don't pick on Cal State
Dominguez Hills right but I may not and
so what do you do with Black Studies out
there or really just right but the thing
is and it is not so much that um but
it's not so much that I'm suggesting
that black students need to get about
the business of majoring in
african-american studies right we're
talking about though people who don't
want to take any classes in
african-american studies when when um at
Cal State Dominguez Hills I know for a
fact it does of them satisfies some of
your requirements right so you would
learn something and be satisfying your
requirements you wouldn't be tripping
yourself up but we have not we I said
you know I'm situated myself as a part
of the problem and this book is a
opportunity for me to start thinking
through what that means I don't think
we've come up with a narrative around
what it is Black Studies does for you
right it can make you smart
alright it introduced you to James
Baldwin which everyone of course needs
to you know immediately pick up
something by Henry but I don't know that
we've come up with or thought that we
had to
come up with any kind of narrative that
addresses just these kinds of concerns
when in doing this book I really came to
see that there was at least at its
institutionalization on the at the
behest of the students who were involved
in it an absolute narrative about what
Black Studies was supposed to do for you
right an absolute understanding an idea
about what it was supposed to do not
just like make you radical but it was
supposed to aid you and your life
chances now we have over the years moved
back from that so we're just happy to
say just take the classes cuz on what it
was supposed to be from their
perspective it was all about addressing
inequality it was all about giving you
the knowledge okay it was prescriptive
african-american studies were supposed
to prescribe issues
I mean prescribe solutions to pressing
social issues it was descriptive it
described the situation that was going
on a description that you wouldn't get
anywhere else and it was um what else I
think those two are the main ones
sort of like scrappy and then you know
just really focused on what was left out
case in point Doug you know I can
remember my godfather telling me that
when he was a applying to go to World
War two that if he said he was Jamaican
he would get a better deal in the army
so this has been a historical thing okay
and I think in dr. David Levin's Lewis's
book they said that they would take a
guy from Harvard and make him a private
and make the guy from you know Alabama
somewhere over him this has been a
historical thing at Princeton Einstein
wrote a letter wondering why it was so
difficult for blacks to attend Princeton
and and to get into Princeton and get
into the studies there Einstein met with
Paul Robeson and they were discussing
these issues so understanding that this
is a longer protracted problem and that
rates is at the center and the birth of
this country and the wealth of this
country is important not only for
african-americans our black mothers
before all America that is absolutely
one side of a long-standing argument let
me just say this and then we'll in like
that is absolutely I go saying that at
all that's it aside of what Morgan
Freeman was saying right I mean why
can't America understand that you know
race is at the center so we can stop
talking about a Black History Month
where there's one month where you do all
this stuff and then anyway let me just
say something and the class I'm teaching
this semester we just showed roots in
class now of course my students this is
from 1977 they were not born which was
out um making me really feel old one of
the things and they were just blown away
by it they just they were just like oh
my god we can't believe that this is
mentioned one of the things that we
talked about is in a number of school
districts around the country just in the
past few years roots has been outlawed
as a teaching tool they actually did a
the senator from Nevada actually you
know spent taxpayer dollars researching
this issue which I'm just not only happy
about that but he what they came up with
is because the n-word is used regularly
in a derisive manner it cannot be taught
which you know I guess there is no
gangsta rap in Nevada or Colorado and I
don't know but that's one thing because
black people are beaten shown to be
beaten in roots it can't be taught and
because whites appear to be kind of mean
it can't be taught they use better
language than this like they really did
use better language than this but
stripped down those are the three
reasons that roots cannot be taught now
if you contrast that with what happened
when roots was actually shown when it
was hailed as a teaching tool when it
was hailed as you know providing spaces
for conversation about race when it was
held it's sort of you know teaching
America that slavery is in fact at the
center of
American narrative like the of an
American narrative and I don't know what
to do with that but you know at least
there was acknowledged meant and
understanding today you're not supposed
to urge some places you're not supposed
to teach it because it might make people
uncomfortable and in that same kind of
way that we want to collapse race and
racism
far too often racism and race becomes
about personal comfort right so this is
really the last thing I'll say so I'm
always hollering at my black students at
Princeton who will say things like
Princeton is a racist institution okay
but why because when I go to the eating
clubs people are mean to me or you know
because my white friends do not
acknowledge me when I walk across you
know the the quad or whatever it's sort
of like you know that's about your
personal comfort and I understand that
we are at a point in American culture
where as I said we have crash crash eyes
the discussion of race everybody you
know is supposed to feel comfortable
around whatever it is that we're talking
about if you are uncomfortable we need
to stop talking about it
posthaste not sort of delve into why
you're uncomfortable what difference it
makes why talking about it might help us
to solve some kinds of issues we don't
we don't want to do that um so yes a
race I believe is it the center of
American history but I think that we're
at a a point in our history and our
present in our contemporary where how we
talk about race and we're not paying
attention we're not paying attention to
how we talk about and don't talk about
race